all right hi welcome everybody it's my
dumb friends Wow we literally just had
10 minutes of the most tense arguments
about how we're making this show work
technically and during a zombie
apocalypse I gotta say that's what this
vibe that's what the vibe of the show is
right now well well then makes it way
more tense by trying to was before we
didn't know I was thinking of references
that's yeah that's that's that's what I
was doing I was trying to be creative
when I was freaking about out of it
thanks a lot Sean yeah that that's me
yeah give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break I was not mad
and I [ __ ] poke to pick up the phone
Sean I was not mad the minute and I'm
frustrated I'm not mad at anybody I'm
frustrated at the situation we have been
doing a thing where we have the guest
story at the end and it's just me Tom
and Sean but we have a very special
guest is Bert Kreischer here everybody
yes everybody thank you it's a pleasure
being thank you for - I love the one
thing that's fun about doing a podcast
is you get to go back like you get to go
and go again I'm gonna I'm gonna find
the new podcast right cuz I'm about to
do it I want to listen yeah I love Shane
Moss yeah he's great right [ __ ] love
Shane Moss you know why that episode was
so good cuz Sean was not you can't take
it you always say that I can't take it
you can't we're like a
turn-of-the-century immigrant couple
like you're on a ship and we never would
have like married in the old country but
now we're scared and alone in a new land
and you need each other yeah
dan made phone calls for Hillary Clinton
today from Oh give me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
phone bag yesterday cuz I don't want a
[ __ ] Donald Trump presidency I posted
online to see if anyone else in the
comedy community wants to do this with
me so we can like fight back against
this [ __ ] and then of course Shawn with
it Shawn is like who you're trying to
Sean who's every [ __ ] pictures of him
with a comedian who's way more famous
than [ __ ] it is [ __ ] him and Colin
Quinn because they're known to have
dinner together you know I didn't say
that a few different [ __ ] tweets dude
50 [ __ ] calls for that [ __ ] yes hi
I'm uh I'm a volunteer from Hillary
Clinton's campaign you list off your
credits off the top Travel Channel and
I'm taking my valuable time to tell you
about our presidential candidate Hillary
Clinton Wow
I have a different approach bird web
series from five [ __ ] years ago
that's what I do are you this is high
early 2000s I know it's the first in
there back its back and is it yeah I
believe so because they're all of a
sudden like back in the day you had to
get a web series in Greenland and
they're throwing money in the
disappeared now you can do one and they
don't ask you what you're gonna do with
the money you can just make it you just
make whatever you want great it's the
Lewis sync thing right so you get to go
make exactly what you want and from
someone who's been in network television
for seven years I'm literally not
network network but cable television
yeah where you do get notes
it's really [ __ ] freeing to be like
hey man you can do whatever
you want look at whatever you want yeah
and then it might turn into a TV show
like I'm obsessed with Action Bronson
[ __ ] that's delicious
yeah yeah no right oh it's great and
it's called [ __ ] that's delicious
no one would ever greenlight a show
called [ __ ] that's delicious
watching ancient aliens that's all and
with other rappers just watching the
show intern aliens yeah I think it's
with what we do with podcasting I think
now that's happening for the Internet
and I think now there's an avenue where
it's it really does affect ticket sales
I don't know if you by the way this is
no I don't know why I'm having this
conversation on this podcast I apologize
yeah but if you follow Google Trends
you'll notice that the more web [ __ ] you
do the more presence you have and the
more ticket sales you sell it's [ __ ]
insane I mean I will I'm trying to get a
third web series off the ground so maybe
that'll I want to do one in this room by
the way I'm for Trump so this is how
[ __ ] serious about this uh-huh I'm
being dead serious think about it no
okay okay pretend no one's raising their
voice at you just let me pitch it
Hillary Clinton does not have the
ability to bring us all together as
humanity Donald Trump with his
assassination will bring us together
like 9/11 when we all like everyone be
like where were you when and it's like
remember you know those moments like
Katrina what everyone has gather yeah
but they can't use make the same
argument with Hillary Clinton it always
gonna kill know what's gonna kill her
they're definitely killing Trump so he's
gonna be our know not a Kennedy it's
like a cuz you were sad when Kennedy got
shot right
half the people be like [ __ ] I remember
where I was that was a great day and
then the other people they go bringing
people together but it will but it will
but it will it'll be like 9/11 but a
happy feeling nobody like nobody we're
not gonna say great saying the Giants
the Patriots fan came together when the
Giants beat the Patriots undefeated
season if someone if someone
had a pipe bomb at one of those games
they'd come together they'd hold hands
away the crimps on the blood did after
the oj verdict remember that right here
right ring give some we need Trump to be
our Rodney King I know you are we bring
him in they'll kill him within the first
[ __ ] month there's no way he's like
game owners they know they have to have
a foresight into this right and then
once he dies we'll get a Republican
Patsy whoever's I don't even know was
when I think of the biggest deaths I
think Cecil the lion harambe and then
Donald Trump that's how I do it it
happens because a bunch of white dude
look think about I mean I ever think
about do the how can you think it's
gonna bring people together as soon as
it happens like [ __ ] white
supremacist are gonna start murdering
black people in Mexico there are no
white white supremacists are cowards
they aren't doing anything [ __ ]
Reverend Al Sharpton sleeps with his
windows open they haven't killed that
guy that wastrel premises are a mockery
yeah they do nothing they [ __ ] have
done nothing we're gonna be in so much
trouble if somebody crawls through Al
Sharpton's window kills him because like
I you think how did he not get
assassinated he says some of the most
volatile things right but it's like I
just don't I think they're ineffective
white supremacists I think that Al
Sharpton's in New York in Harlem you
know is he no no no Haram [ __ ] that was
just race you shoeshines early in the
morning Jesus no I'm not gonna vote at
all that's the real answer I'm not gonna
vote cuz I like Bill Clinton mm-hmm I
don't know man Hillary do you really
like her is your face
I don't like her but I'm like I'm also
not like I like her way more than Trump
yeah how you supposed to pick no but
it's not like you know it's not like I'm
not going paintballing on the weekend do
you know what I mean picking a president
you got to make hard decisions I want to
know
she just didn't speak up when he [ __ ]
other chicks so much more badass though
to like stay with the guy for your own
power to have your self-assessment
you'll be like jealousy okay sell that
to me well I did the fat I mean it's
that it's I'm not saying anything dude
I've ever been cuckolded have I ever
been yeah I pay Aaron to do it and oh
thanks
no I I mean it's the same argument that
a lot of women have and a lot of men
have is that her staying with Bill
Clinton was the most subversive thing
she could do because she used that to
launch her own political career yeah
like you know and you got to appreciate
someone who takes one to the chest for
exactly exactly
he took it for the country yes she could
be like [ __ ] this guy and walk out right
exactly and it would have destroyed she
could have been rich like she would have
made a ton of money you know what I mean
like so she's doing it because she does
have a bigger principle and my guess you
I guess you have to I never looked at it
that way you have to say cuz I've been
cuckolded before and it sucks
yeah and no part of me was ever no-knock
holden yeah who cuckold of you my best
friend haha [ __ ] my girlfriend give me
Jesus I was only the second chick I've
ever slept with I was 20 22 24 sorry
it was dude it ruined me and I'm like
and it but there's no the thing that
what happened he fight him afterwards
and I know this is too sad right it was
like it was just destructive man it's
it's you know what it is it's the people
talking about you
when you're not there and you know
they're doing it that's what really
destroys you that's where it [ __ ]
kills your ego when you go into a bar
and people see you and they they
approach you as if they've been talking
about you like like you've been hey it's
a bird oh he's here and you're like he's
here it was intense man and then he
pulled that thing where when one friend
the guy here when he found out the
friend who [ __ ] the girlfriend said
you can you can punch me in the face if
you want which is such a [ __ ] snake
move to do where you think the person
that got cuckolded feels guilty because
they want to hit you in the face
yeah my friend has had it much worse
that that moment [ __ ] him up more than
me meaning like I got right I got like I
got empathy he got he lost a lot of
friends in that and he lost a girlfriend
and then him and that girl never stayed
together and then and then and I and I
if you look at his life heading it's
very I mean I'm just being candid it's
very sad a lot of sad so when I when I
cheated you know I lost a lot of those
friends but you need that like I was
talking I was talking with with somebody
at work and he was he was telling me
about like you know I like this one guy
was a politician in the end he sent out
pamphlets in the wrong way and he got
busted and it wasn't that big of a deal
but because he tried to cover it up he
got in big trouble he went to jail for a
year or something but like having a
consequence helps you move on you know
like if you would have it that way like
like getting away with sometimes living
away with it is worse is your rice a
consequence like my biggest problem
right now is like I get on podcasts and
I and I don't I don't ever disagree if
someone talked [ __ ] about someone I
don't ever disagree and sometimes I will
chime in cuz that's my personality and
that's my biggest flaw right now and I'm
trying to work on it
cuz I'll just stand up for ya we're just
like like if you just started talking
[ __ ] about someone I just would agree it
does matter it is I'd be like
ah but also what people always talk [ __ ]
like I've definitely been a room where I
start talking [ __ ] with somebody and
then they're like yeah he's a really
good friend of mine but like it's that
person's job to to be like hey you know
like I'm not arrogant enough to think
that like like you know like that I can
have a friend that friend has to defend
me from everyone who doesn't like me you
know like because I've done stuff that
you know I was probably annoyed people
and piss people off so it's like I'm not
I'm not immune from that I'm at the
point now right a friend who got really
[ __ ] up this weekend in Phoenix and
was the end was like apologetic the next
day I was like nope wrong guy you don't
ever have to apologize to me I've done
that to so many [ __ ] people yeah
there is everyone gets a free pass
getting hammered around me everybody
yeah yeah you're the guy to drink well
yeah you'll never you'll never do
anything I mean you could I mean I'm so
what's the what's the worst thing that
somebody's done to you when when you've
been drunk as far as like put you in a
situation that you're like what the [ __ ]
did oh I don't have that oh I don't know
because I like like I've just I've been
putting so like I so many [ __ ] bad
that like there's nothing there's no
like be I've been in parties where
people break out heroin and you're like
he's like going charge it like oh you
know what I'm gonna back up from this
this is too crazy yeah for a couple
times a time guns show up yeah the
government a lot of situations where gun
comes out on the table and 22 I was I
mean for anyone who doesn't know I have
a story that's online you can find it
right now I'm probably rushing off you
when I was a kid and robbed a train but
uh one of the time one of the times I
was partying with these guys we were
whole class taken like a field trip to
get an alright boat and I was class the
whole class the whole class and so my
best friends in college this is in
college studying abroad in st.
Petersburg okay cool and the guy my best
friend's a beers reporter no no that's
where I was born oddly enough oh yeah
and and so that one of the gangsters the
next day my best friend Igor was the
guy's name Oh ruthless we were supposed
to go whole class on a boat is like the
big Russian Mayday everyone knows
on the cab River and everyone parties
and I go over to his room in the morning
and he goes I go I am ready for the boat
trip and he's like no bulk I go what and
he's all friends with arrows boys we're
all drinking beer eating fish and he's
like no boat I got no [ __ ] boat I
have no idea but everyone says but
there's no [ __ ] boat and so we get
the teachers come down they're like you
ready he goes let's go by the ohms so we
all grab the beer and we start walking
to a dock I know we don't have a boat
for like I know and all these guys to
know we don't have a [ __ ] boat my
whole classes get the like seasickness
wristbands
yeah Poncho's cameras are so [ __ ]
ready all of a sudden one of his buddies
comes out Igor we have vault and
everyone goes like we're bought we show
up [ __ ] boat do you remember the
movie um remember the Sex Pistols movie
said Nancy for the boat they got they
got arrested on at the very beginning in
the movie it's it looks exactly like
that boat that's all my reference yeah
and so we go in we get on the boat we
load it up everyone's on the boat and
then the dock master comes down and he's
like a gentleman I don't need papers or
whatever and the one guy lifts his shirt
up and goes shows a gun and he was here
your [ __ ] papers and the guy's like
back by three and so we went to the
bottom the back of the galley of the
boat like guts of the boat when the guy
pulled his gun out and put it on the
table I remember being like first time
I've ever been in that situation and I
was like I didn't know what to do and I
got one of the teachers and I was like
hey just give me a heads up there's a
guy with a gun out on the table and
we're all drinking he's been drinking
and there's a whole class that knows has
no idea we stole a boat they were like
just go down and drink with them and
keep him calm and I remember telling
Igor and Igor said to him he's like man
puts gun put it on the way and he's like
where are they [ __ ] children and he's
waving it around so I was like this is
[ __ ] gun who gives a [ __ ] pochet
and I remember being like this is how
someone gets shot like literally
terrified and then we're all good so you
didn't leave no I didn't I had to drink
that was a lot of the times I've gotten
in that Tron that trip I had to drink
with the gangsters cuz I could calm him
down I could like I was just what would
you talk to him about I would do I would
I would learn how to
a movie quotes and Russian just do like
give us one I forgot
I used to fat guy in a little coat
[ __ ] I forgot to do it but I used to
do it to those guys I used to do I used
to quote rap lyrics I used to say things
in an American like one of the ones I
would used to always say that everyone
was yeah de volta you coschka which
means I work [ __ ] but it really means I
work with cats during the day it was a
really fun really [ __ ] fun summer
well that was the first time I saw a gun
any time a gun comes out and I've been
plenty of times I was at one of the
biggest coke dealers in LA when I first
came out here the first time go out to
this guy's house I wish I could tell you
the whole story cuz it's so much better
yeah I would rat out a bunch of
comedians yeah suffice to say one guy
when I first moved to New York
introduced us to his drug dealer and
called him Billy and so that's what we
called Billy on the street
to Puerto Rican guys and we call people
and we call and so that was our cookies
the least Puerto Rican name I've ever
heard that's we call cocaine Billy so
people go hey want to get Billy tonight
yeah I called Billy see if Billy wants
to party and so we'd get cocaine we
called Billy um so uh this guy dude
cocaine now no no I'm [ __ ] 43 I have
high blood pressure last time I did
cocaine probably was honestly probably
15 years ago yeah I haven't done drugs
really at all but when I was young I was
a party animal yeah and so uh so this
guy that's it that was our hookup and
that wasn't you never even thought much
about it so I go to the biggest cocaine
dealers house in LA and I run into said
comedian I won't name the guy oral but I
run into said comedian has Steve Harvey
doing but he would make the funnest face
though if you got bad coke like that
face like this this is [ __ ] face
yeah
she was in the bathroom with another
comedian and I saw both of them and I
was like what's going on and they looked
at me like they saw a [ __ ] like I saw
a ghost I'm gonna be doing here no I was
like I don't know this guy has this
guy's liked of my friends nose and he's
like the biggest coke dealer in LA and
then he just the coke dealer comes up
and puts his arm around me he goes
what's her name said I gotta meet you
you're comedian you know these guys I
said yeah and then they go this is Billy
know what he was like what Bill named as
cocaine in the streets of New York I was
like yeah I probably should have said
his real name in this whole thing now
Billy's a pseudonym
yeah Billy's a pseudonym for coke yeah
oh yeah last time yeah it was yeah and
he was he had a he had a screen this is
like one of the most beautiful things
I've ever seen in my life he had a
screen I want to say it was all like a
like a pendulum or something but it was
like a scream that you could tilt and he
would add a rock of cocaine who's a
product purist cocaine I've ever done in
my life and he would shave it on the
screen and it would snow flake on to the
onto the marble countertop and he just
carve a line and it was like and I
remember I did one bump on my one Lynam
on my right side and immediately and
I've only had this happen like two or
three times immediately a line down the
center of my face was drawn and the
right side went numb
and I went my teeth from my Center right
tooth all the way back and I was like
yeah that's some good coke it was
amazing that's some great cocaine
no I I've done it like um last time I
did it was like less than like oh I run
two years ago
yeah um and I've been sober for now are
you sober sober yeah you're in like a
half yeah so do the math you know I got
in really I didn't have
fun time with it but yeah I mean it's
ain't now it actually makes me sick to
think about it oh I could never the day
after was I mean the worst day I've ever
had in my life every [ __ ] time yeah
I've only done it a handful of times
probably yeah but that word that next
day it's not like it's not fun and I
feel like T you get to nage once you
start to hit your thirties man doing
drugs isn't like what do you I mean if
you smoke pot great that's fine I I
don't but if you do that's a different
thing but I like doing hard drugs yeah
even like mushrooms man I can't do like
mushroom like I can't imagine I feel
like I've realized enough in my life to
note like to have mushrooms in my 30s
and like you know like the realizations
aren't gonna be fun you know yeah and I
and I can I can't I know from personal
experience I can't just giggle away the
night cuz I do have responsibilities in
this world number one being my two
children right and the fact that they
and my brain working to mean for me to
make a living isn't fun yeah you never
want to have to say to your kids hey be
cool be [ __ ] cool right oh yeah
you're just not drinking right now yeah
just I've been I mean I've just been not
I'm not like for no for no reason at all
honestly the biggest thing was um flying
I I've always drank when I flow yeah
yeah it does it does make it have you
ever gotten hammered before flight like
hammered hammered I've all I've been
I've only been able to get on a plane by
drinking for the Pat for my entire life
I've never once done it it is it is it's
very nerve inducing and so and so
recently I flew to Syracuse and oof just
an early flight and I usually pack it
you doing funny button there some funny
bone Sara boots the mall and a early
flight I usually I packed little Jack
Daniels bottles with me and I pour my do
you ever show that night uh yeah yeah
show that night and so I'm like alright
load it up and I get five in the morning
I'm in the bathroom to pour myself a
little roadie in my swell and I forgot
the booze and so I had to Phi was forced
to take off sober and it wasn't that bad
and I went oh I wonder if I cannot drink
on this flight and I didn't
all the way to Chicago and I felt good
and then I didn't drink all the way to
Syracuse and I felt good and I went this
is really confusing cuz I've always been
like right panic flyer and so I tried to
do on the right way home didn't drink
that weekend I just didn't want to drink
I just never did you ate the shows
better no I mean it doesn't matter I do
stand-up sober mostly I don't bring
booze onstage with me yeah like if I
drink I'm not that great on if I get
[ __ ] hammered the crowd loves it but
I'm not that good I go long and I'm a
little I'm a little gluttonous but the
didn't drink on the way home and I was
like okay this is a fluke this is just
something that's going on in my system
yeah didn't drink for I jet and by the
way not not didn't drink because of any
[ __ ] reason other than I was feeling
really good I was feeling really
creative and I was feeling healthy and I
was losing weight I was like you know
what [ __ ] it I'm not gonna drink so I
got to go to Phoenix had to fly oh sorry
I'm trying to see if I can not drink on
this flight and I didn't bring on the
flight to Phoenix I was like whatever
and then I drank a couple nights in
Phoenix and then stopped again and I was
like okay like I couldn't figure out
what was going on I've always been a big
big brand drinker and so I was just like
I'm not gonna question it I'm just gonna
whatever feels natural like it's always
felt natural to have a bottle of wine at
the end of the day and so I never
questioned it
so I'm miss young I'm not gonna question
it I'm just partying what if I wasn't
party if I don't I mean I've gotten so
jura like I remember I had bought a
bunch of beers for my row on a flight
once and this is like right before I
went to rehab oh yeah
Oh rehab so bad is what it is was it
like a court-appointed we now know I I
was trying to like win my girlfriend
back at the time and I had [ __ ] up and
whatever she's doing good now nice
person but not a girlfriend anymore but
anyway I don't know why I said it like
the end of a Tom Waits song we're in uh
we're in a row on this flight and it was
like like like I immediately ordered
beers for the people next to me because
I don't want to drink alone and and then
and then the guy next to me cuz guess
I'm gonna have to give you those and he
has like a little little liquor bottles
right cuz I'm gonna have to give you
guys a couple of these and then the girl
to the left of me goes guess I'm gonna
help you guys out with these and she
just takes a huge bag as an ex out and
we all just kind of look at each other
like
welcome to the part but we like I don't
like people who need in it like it
wasn't like fun we were just like it was
like bookies counting money yeah that's
like we were there to like hey we're
medicating right now we're not partying
we're [ __ ] medicating you know that's
I I did that with a doctor one time yeah
it is a long time ago when I was living
in New York do and doing stand-up and I
was flying down to Florida and he gave
me the best advice I ever got I was like
I was like sometimes I get cut off on
planes and it was like I was most been
25 years old 26 26 years old and he goes
you talk entirely too much he's like
don't he's like cut your words in half
don't speak to the flight attendants is
this it's loud you got noise reduction
headsets on you're shouting at them
you're I need a beer like you go stop
talking point to your glass get her eye
contact with her fingers like wave to
her point your glass and that's it
and I went really he goes yeah you need
to chill the [ __ ] out he goes you're
you're a lot of Energy's like you're
drinking during this appointment yeah
and so and so the doctor was on the
plane next to me I'm on a plane next to
each other
and so I go so I saw that he's like what
do you do I said I'm a comedian so what
are you doing so I'm a doctor he's like
he's like if you want I can give you a
little bit of a xanax we'll [ __ ]
chill the [ __ ] out he's my age look and
play a little older maybe 32 yeah so we
split his hand axe and ice kicks in and
I'm [ __ ] feeling amazing and then all
of a sudden this baby they say they come
up on the thing and they're like ladies
and gentlemen we have a sick baby on the
plane is there a doctor in here and I
raise my hand next to me Oh as a doctor
and they're like oh thank you sir and
the [ __ ] you doing man I was like you're
a doctor he's like [ __ ] hammered and
I was like I'm sorry he's like ah [ __ ]
and they may came back and like sir you
a doctor I was like nobody is the baby
and the guy is one of the one of the
quickest things I've ever seen happened
he comes back he was buckle up Orlando
right now I said what and he's like
we're landing right now we won't be able
to make it at an but this date baby's
gonna die I was like what and the baby
has like a hundred seven temperature um
and he's like he's like and we did an
emergency landing in Orlando and they
[ __ ] rushed out ambulances the guy in
the pilot was like ladies and gentlemen
you are going to feel like we are
crashing we are not we are making a dive
into Orlando we will be touching down in
two minute
and literally and we stopped on a dime
they were on the plane within minutes
took the baby off taxi back out took off
landed in Tampa and I was like oh yeah
yeah 26 years old probably so that is
that sounds like I got MBC shy drunk
doctor or something
drunk drunk drunk flight doctor I don't
really have a great title for it but
that's uh you saved somebody's life you
saved a baby's life technically I saved
a baby's life by just your your
superpower is you're pointing at people
who are more equipped to do no it's it's
I wish I could turn this into a bit but
it's putting my hand up like like I have
I have a tendency to put my hand up
instincts when I know the answer we did
traffic school I did travel school in LA
out and like daddy you know one time our
teacher comes in with a baby arm and
he's like immediately he's like he's
like okay like his arms like a little
real thin and I'm literally sticking out
like he's hailing a cab yeah he's all
right real quick let's get it outta way
who notices something different about me
and my hand went up no one else put
their hands up
no one else he's like you you seem to
notice something different about me and
I'm now I'm thinking I don't know how to
say well yeah I don't know how to say it
you can't say baby i atrophied like an
atrophic limb what do I say and I'm
sitting there my hands still up I'm
trying to think of how to say it and the
guy behind me leans up to my back and he
goes it's his arm I started laughing so
[ __ ] hard he's like it's his arm and
I and the guy goes and I I think I said
your arm and then the guy said they he
got hit in the back he was bringing
crates it used to work for Ralph's yeah
he's bringing crates in and those
automatic doors just one clipped him in
the shoulder and sort of kind of hurt
he's and the next you know he had a baby
arm oh I thought it would say you're the
athlete
wait a minute so the arm like shrinks it
dude it's very let me tell you that true
is that that's a good area now I've now
I've I've done research because I
thought I was getting a baby arm yeah
and from like see I sleep on my shoulder
and what can happen is you can pinch a
nerve in your neck or in your arm and it
will affect your arm and it'll it'll
it's happening to a professional fighter
bas Rutten he's had a number of
surgeries because your arm atrophies
it's the muscles falling away and it
totally happens - it really happens oh
my god it shrank as well it shrinks it
you can't you if you start noticing that
you don't have as much muscle in it and
then all of a sudden it just starts
shrinking and it atrophies it's very
common and it happens from like a neck
injury or a shoulder injury or a back
injury I actually have a baby sense of
self-worth that's really Oh mom let me
started about self-worth
I'll [ __ ] just of my ego my ego I
call big brain little brain yeah big
brains the dick who says this [ __ ] that
you don't want to hear little brains
your mom like it's gonna be okay
yeah then we make them [ __ ] and [ __ ]
big brain my big Bryant brains a [ __ ]
beast it is oh why what's going on I got
this I don't know if you noticed I'm
going through the shaming campaign right
now with Tom Segura
mm-hm and started off as a joke but it
just hasn't ended yeah and so you once
you get you guys fat shaming each other
yeah and but I'm losing the battle
aggressively aggressively like Hausa
like he's just he's just better at
burying you his fans just won't let him
lose like and my fans are his fans also
and and it's funnier to watch me it's
funnier to watch me get worked up then
because he just won't get work so some
of it hurts 100% whatever what are these
people saying it burn let me get online
I mean if you go on my Twitter you'll if
you just type in I'll just type in being
Shawn actually do that - we fat we fat
shame each other all the time you're
right
as I agree that's that that's my bad if
it's people is people send pictures they
photoshopped pictures you might see a
picture that cuts to my soul yeah this
like this picture I it it is the perfect
photoshopped picture to make you feel
disgusted about your body oh Jesus they
photoshopped the stomach because you're
not that big
no they photoshopped the stomach apples
so it looks like fake tits like his tits
look like he had a he had a boob job and
they put on the nipples and the most
likes like soap receta
like I read thin little wife's nipples
and they're probably the size of
probably two inches around yeah and so
they photoshop puffy nipples on me it's
gross it's it's really gross but you all
because your podcast picture is is you
shirtless like touching your tent yeah
I'm in performed with a shirt on in five
years I just did my hour suppose I just
did an hour special for show time
shirtless congratulations
one time a buddy of mine told me I look
like Michael Moore from behind even if
you told Michael Moore you look like
Michael Moore from behind abig take it
easy it's just it's just I think it's
just it's like if you just read them
like these are all from today hey don't
worry about burpees burps all the time
when he eats double pipe Issac burbot
Berta's fat uh-huh let your parents know
your kids are gonna live without a
father you're fat like it's just home
some people don't know how to write a
joke like some people just write think
oh I get it by the means I mean II yeah
this is gonna work
yeah a lot of it's about Tom is the food
check the water champ and I'm the food
champ and then and then you do something
funny and like and like like I go on
rate I go on TV and I do this joke about
Tom and it's really funny gets a laugh
yeah and then and they they just they
just discredit it they're like no that's
not good
Tom's better and you're like [ __ ] you
and then because they want you to get
worked up right like at one point like I
wrote this song called The Ballad of big
Tommy buns yeah and I put it at the
front of my podcast for free it's [ __ ]
free it's Geoffrey and then and it's
just making fun of Tom saying like
little by the way they're all my little
food eccentricities but I put him on Tom
yeah he lays his skittles out on his bed
and names each one that he dips his
pizza and rants like I really do with
skittles
no no Eminem's pizza and rant oh yeah
it's really good oh and then if you put
sriracha in the RAM oh my god it is
really good legit dude dude you and me
would kill each other if we like if we
hung out for a week I feel like just
food wise it's not even drinking wise
can't handle an iced coffee right now I
have I have real food problems like yeah
shit's bad
like yesterday my wife and I are on this
diet and then we goes we're driving from
FEMA really good diet for you is just
like not eating a ham in the car no for
me is juice in the morning yeah no booze
at night like a punk because I'll lose
weight really quickly if I don't drink
yeah no booze at night lean protein and
then something sensible for dinner but
light and so yesterday was our cheat day
and she literally one point was like hey
you're gonna make me feel like I can't
have cheat days if I know you're gonna
eat like this cuz you'll die I got a six
dollar burger from Carl's jr. if I got
the bacon cheddar cheese fries I got a
ten-piece nugget from Carl's jr. I got
regular fries and then I got just like a
regular cheeseburger cuz I like the
regular cheeseburgers here
yeah God and then I went in and then I
went into the grocery store and got
Reese's peanut butter cups butterfingers
a score bar and and and the other one a
heath bar and my website see what the
[ __ ] you doing and I was like it's a
cheat day oh I'm taking this [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] mattresses exactly no no no your
about your love to have some bread
that's it and I was like [ __ ] that my
cheek it was aggressive it's tough man
it's just so good it's just so good
anyone who says like I'm food is that I
quit cigarettes four months ago you did
I have yeah I haven't had any drinks or
drugs and I probably a year and a half
now or close to it are you keeping up
with like not like how long you been
sober
yeah okay you're like a meeting yeah
really yeah those are fun I went alone
time um some of them are some of the one
I went to was a blast the one I went to
this morning was was fine oh you won't
wonder this morning's I did you
should've buy the one by my house which
one is that I don't know do I see them
every morning um what if I Bennett you
it was Scientology and you didn't know
where the same thing
you talked about eatin strapped inside
yeah um I do Scientology they don't
they're not too crazy you're a
Scientologist no I do it though what do
you mean you do it like wouldn't you you
do it
I'd do it like like it's like it's like
playing the harmonica okay
they said pick a religion religion okay
what are you gonna pick you've got a one
it's Josh I'm like okay like Chris like
a lower I got like a more liberal form
of Christianity or Buddhism okay
Buddhism is just two and maybe maybe
maybe like maybe ever
also maybe we'll do Judaism too like
something uh yeah maybe but that's just
for the entertainment connections yeah
okay but then all those like like
Buddhism is something that I go yeah I'd
pick it but I don't know if I could
really do it cuz they have to be like
chill well I mean with anything like you
know like you know I've gotten away from
meditation but all that kind of stuff
like how
you become more chill it works I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
everything III need a couple things to
make me just normal yeah and in you know
like I have a couple different things
that I do see I look at Scientology is
like okay like this I got pitched this
way to buy Scientologist one time and
all of a sudden it made sense like I
don't I believe I'm Christian or
Catholic I'm Catholic right
not like practicing but I subscribe to
the doctrine
I believe in JC but like do I really
truthfully believe that Mary was a
virgin had a baby
not after I was done with her like like
all this [ __ ] that they write in the
book do I really believe it or do I
kindness no no but I'll tell you what I
really believe there's aliens out there
like I really I do - yeah and that's and
that's Scientology so part of me is like
[ __ ] I could actually believe in their
[ __ ] like they if they put me out a book
they'd be like no this is it yeah I
believe in aliens too but if you name a
spit like if you're like are there
Islands out there yes and then but if
somebody's like I know there's alien
named Greg I'd be like you're full [ __ ]
I can't believe it but if you have any
facts to your alien knowledge I think
you're full of [ __ ]
okay that maybe you're right about
influence I may get you to kill the
mayor after this I'll just tell you it
is it it's Aaron kill him right now
mayor that kept the wife's last name
because it's Mexican oh I forget I love
that guy yeah like Smith isn't he
Mexican no no is jalapeno poppers real
as hell are well are so he added reveal
our ago so to it so he took like some of
his buddies still Mexican same as Carlos
Mencia he just caught us
so he was like you know wasn't selling
tickets right but well that's crazy
because he was ripping off other Bay her
speech snow he did a whole section of
his speech that was George Lopez's it
was really oh I haven't seen coliseum
forever
now Ivan he's my roommate no he's not
um what's your worst bomb that you've
ever had oh and and and on you like a
decision you made on stage oh oh there's
no questions I've had a I've had a
couple the worst one no doubt and I hope
to god I pray that the I'm sure there's
tape on it and I nobody never gets out
what is this
Ian bagg used to do a show called the
Ian bagg show it was a live interview
show in LA in LA okay and it was really
fun to do and I did I did
Byron allen's comics unleashed that
afternoon uh and like and I was like I
don't want to do this but then I walked
it I got there and like Dennis Miller
was there it was like the bit some of
the biggest names in class fellers here
and then we got done in everyone I'm not
saying the tenant was drinking I don't
remember if he was per se or not but
everyone had done the show all these big
names were all drinking after the show
and I was like I knew I had to do him
back show buffs yeah I don't care I
don't as a rule of thumb I don't like to
go on stage [ __ ] hammered right but I
went I went to in bag show [ __ ]
hammered yeah and I got on stage I made
some joke I made a joke
the joke was do you ever see the same
person you ever see the same stranger
twice in one day like yeah like you see
them then coughing then all the sudden
later you see them driving on Street
like shut up
I saw the same Asian lady forty five
times today yeah I know she was she did
my laundry she looked like whatever in
the new keep explain the first part
doesn't get a laugh and then your ago if
I explain the racism they'll get it yeah
and they didn't they didn't want to hear
it and then I said and then they go it's
not that's not true I know it well
actually no I know it it's I was look
the jokes based off of the fact that not
all Asians look alike but they all do a
lot of them have the exact same hair
color so I imagine if you went to
Australia and you saw all blond hair you
want people they oh you'd start being
like which ones man
it goes from just like a joke the
defense to like then like explaining it
like David Duke or explaining like
whatever new new genex or whatever it's
called eugenic yeah and then ice and
then the gay and then this guy in the
audience goes well well black people
have all the same hair color but no
we're having a conversation about it
right just [ __ ] spiraling a white
Catholic guy how races work and so no
and so I start saying listen if you know
about it then it's true if you know
about it then it had to have been like
if I said all you people look alike and
you've heard that before you haven't
heard that just because I say I go I'm
not the first person to say it and so
ice and the guys like you're being
racist I go no I get that but you're
denying that racism exists and he's like
he's like there is no rate I don't I'm
not racist and I've never known anyone
racist you're the first person like no
I'm not racist I'm just being real right
now I mean I'm gonna [ __ ] you and I look
now ian has a black band on stage with
them all black I'm under the impression
that they're all my team because we're
all on stage yet so I look to one of the
black guys I go tell this [ __ ] kid
that racism is real and he's like hey
this is your [ __ ] hole very small and
by the way and IANS trying to get me out
of it but I won't let it go I'm like no
I'm like no you're [ __ ] telling me
that like and no one knew who Tom Segura
was at the time but I go Tom Segura and
I look similar we look we have same hair
color you can you could say if you saw
both of us all wheat why people guys it
isn't it and I'm [ __ ] spiraling out of
control and then and by weight is a week
before Michael Richards thing yeah
there's a week before it and I go um
and I go see you've never said the N
word to this kid enough this guy in the
front row and he's like no never I said
you never sung it and he goes what I
said you own listen to hip-hop he was
not listen to hip-hop
when you sing hip-hop when you sing DMX
you just don't sing that word that's a
lot you're lying right now and he goes
no I'm not I said when I get to the word
I just mumble it I know what you're
[ __ ] lying and I'm [ __ ] losing and
I look to the back I go tell this kid
that racism drill I go have you ever
been called the n-word and he looks at
me and he goes son I have not and if you
start right now we're gonna have a
problem and I was like oh like and and I
go I think I'm done and I just got off
the stage and they went nuts and they
started applauding oh my god it's
amazing I was [ __ ] so bad and you know
I love like some people will tell like a
bombing story on here and it won't be
it'll be like kind of make it well you
don't make the crowd look bad more than
them this was like well it's always our
fault it's never the crowd like right
a lot of [ __ ] I mean everyone here's
the other thing though here's the other
thing we're in LA so the majority of
comics you're gonna have in LA aren't
Road comics there's just la comics they
do meltdown they do the store they do
the improv they do you see be and so I
think I think there's this this
disconnection with what comedy in front
of strangers is like yeah like doing
comment at the store it's great there's
a lot of what you could call strangers
but they're all comedy fans their
parents because they get good comedy and
so if you do good [ __ ] they'll get it
and if you [ __ ] do hacky [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] know it's hacky but like on the
road man I it's I [ __ ] it's gotten
bad yeah like oh like like I did miami
one time and they were all [ __ ] like
it was Steve Trevino I couldn't sell any
tickets Oh Joel had to have Steve
Trevino head co-headline with me Steve
had his own feature act so I had my own
feature act and I know it was like for a
Latino comics going up in front of me
then me and then I got to do an hour
dude you do not know bombing
like there's a moment where you realize
I've tried my best stuff I know sweats
dripping off my chin onto my shirt oh my
god and I know that they see it but I
can't stop this and
in those moments my name is Bert I know
you're thinking hot sexy name do you do
porn
first laps anyone here during sex that
always works
you know what cops hate and someone's
like you did my setup for a joke that
was gonna last four minutes that it
usually works nope I was talking my
black friend the other day you don't
know black people they were just taking
my legs out so then finally sorry that's
Thursday night Friday night's worse
Friday Late Show I asked Steve if we can
trade and I can go before him says no he
doesn't want this [ __ ] it [ __ ] spot
because they're all doing 20 minutes
yeah and so Saturday I just do an hour
an hour of silence so this whole weekend
you're bombing no one no one's bomb like
this ever you've never seen it before
you oh yeah
Ricky Cruz is doing 15 DJ Kue DJ couch
is doing 15 Ricky Cruz is doing 20
Steve's Raveena's doing 30 to 40 and I
have to do an hour I find that I'm gonna
show with a net guy named DJ and a
bombing so uh it it was so bad and then
and then Saturday early show I just gave
up I gave up and I go and I resigned to
the fact that they didn't like me and so
I go I get on stage and I'm like I go
okay I tell first few jokes and it just
starts again it just starts again this
[ __ ] thing where it's like you're
like this is the reason I would quit
comedy cuz yeah I can't get a joke to to
get any liftoff
I'm just piling down the runway and
seeing the fence going this is gonna
vote we're gonna end up in the ocean
yeah Jesus so I'm like [ __ ] you guys and
that's when they start after you you're
like [ __ ] you guys and then they start
to get behind just go you know what I
don't think
have you guys speak English so let's get
a Cuban guy up here
you gotta translate my jokes to these
[ __ ] people and yeah bring a [ __ ]
Cooper knows then I go give me the
thuggish black guy in here thuggish like
gold fronts [ __ ] braids bring him up
here so now I have you know the guys
straight out of the wire and then this
[ __ ] Cuban guy and I go let's just
let's start my show all over again I go
you guys just talk to your people and
say it the way you'd say it I go I was
talking to a girl the other day and then
I give the bike out of microphone it
goes man I'm like yo yo gonna play get
some conversation he just says it in
Spanish what I took money and they
[ __ ] gonna and I just I told no jokes
and then the one joke the one joke that
I thought was funny as [ __ ] flat line
because it is by the print if you had to
pick what the dumbest thing you've ever
[ __ ] done in your entire life I got
it okay you got it no questions asked
okay by the way I'm gonna preface this
I'm gonna preface this with I did not
know it was dumb I thought everyone did
it until I said it one night and my
friend said that's the dumbest thing
I've ever [ __ ] heard and I just
recently have started trying to figure
out how to talk about on stage but it's
so dumb people are God God's trouble
okay I used to think Anne Frank and
Helen Keller were the same person like
into my 20s no joke and I had a joke
about Anne Frank I had a joke about
Helen Keller and the whole time I [ __ ]
it up I thought they were the same
[ __ ] person
you know what I found out at the end
prank house yeah how do you think she
owes that why kid it's because of an
salty it's cuz an sono should have no
problem being quiet cuz when I was a kid
I saw the miracle worker and it just
stuck with me yeah and and so I kind of
I didn't remember Helen Keller's name
right
I remembered and Sullivan I don't know
why I had a friend named Jason Sullivan
so I think maybe so an was the name I
thought and so when people said Anne
Frank I immediately thought they were
talking about Helen Keller Oh miracle
workers story yeah and so I would be
like oh yeah I know that one and so I
know that one and so and by the way
Helen Keller now these are all things
that like I was a very pedestrian
academic meaning I never really read
[ __ ] books I never like if you said
something I kind of heard you and then I
plugged that into what I believed was
information so like I could say [ __ ]
that you'd be like what the [ __ ]
and so well my whole life Helen Keller
jokes were like the biggest thing in the
world like that was like yes there was
yeah Helen Keller jokes so we're in
Amsterdam we're in we're we're staying
in like a hostel and my buddies Tyler PJ
Chad and we Cho are like I'm the whole
time I'm like let's just kick it okay we
will get mushrooms get [ __ ] hammered
go to a live sex show and they're like
well there's a lot of culture we should
go to damned Frank house and I'm like
[ __ ] yes I go we'll just get high as
[ __ ] and laugh our dicks off and they're
like oh yeah you can go in the [ __ ]
house and they're like yeah it's a
towards the house I mean I mean you can
see like the closet the captor and I'm
like they kept in the [ __ ] closet but
the whole time I'm thinking this is
[ __ ] why are we making why would this
be a funny thing I'm like I think he
kept drona they didn't put that in the
movie like the Nazis were looking for I
go the [ __ ] so we end up
by a long way we end up calling them
Frank house getting highest draft Buzzi
and I'm just started - I just told Helen
Keller jokes whole time the whole thing
I'm not home until this woman turns
around goes are you telling Helen Keller
jokes and I was like I am wait I am
who's this chick and they're like they
tell me I'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is that was I was 23 years old
yeah by the way I'm not I'm not I'm the
perfect person for the show because I
have a million things like that right
yeah I just did I never really did the
math dude we have to have you back then
can you come back the one thing we do we
usually we know this week's episode was
a little different we didn't do many
segments with one thing we do end on
every week is a Tom has he's had a rough
life so every week he tells us haunting
realization Tom do you have one for this
week oh sure yeah I could share I could
share one can you hear me yeah me oh I
have my fingers all the time yeah sorry
I snapped my fingers as nervous habit
it's crazy all right
um or you've got the beat who never say
got the beat again you're the widest
voice I've ever heard exactly an hour
every week we try to do like an hour
around a little bit over especially cuz
like with your stories I'd rather have
you back and just doing the other
[ __ ] thing you know yeah
all right Tom so the Olympics today
where the Olympics are still happening
and they did the first open water swim
which everyone is reassured about with
the pollution and I I used to do open
water swims in in San Francisco Bay
which are it's that I mean you get the
shits there too it's it's what happens
there's a lot of there's pollution and I
think just salt water is a natural
laxative when you drink a bunch of it so
I was thinking about when I did a
saltwater swim and I couldn't believe
that we did this this is this is a while
back but we did this thing where it
called the bridge slim where you swim
from four points on the south side the
golden brick gate bridge over to the
north side which was I think at the time
they had a couple kayaks and a jet ski
now I think they have all these boats
and escorts I don't know why they
thought this would be a good idea or why
I got in the water because I guess I was
I had problems but um so we jumped in
the water and we're swimming across and
they don't stop the ships they the ships
don't care there's like a couple major
ports and so some kind of giant cargo
ship is coming towards us while we're
swimming and they're about six stories
tall yeah and when you're flat on the
water you're looking up six stories and
this thing it's just coming at you and
so you swim faster like it was a great
motivator to swim and there are people
in the kayaks yelling at us because you
didn't just have to clear the boat but
the propwash could suck you back into
the GS
not to mention the currents and
everything that are there so we're
swimming our [ __ ] guts out and we get
over to the other side and this is
something I I don't know why I was
unclear about this but we get over to
the other side and I'm like okay that
was Wow we made it this is great and
then they said touch the rock now you
have to go back okay and so I did and I
had the shit's for three days afterwards
why'd you why'd you think that because
you kid there's no way yeah because
there's no way to get like you would
have to walk barefoot like you know in
your swimsuit across the Golden Gate
Bridge you could have gotten an uber
yeah this is this is this is 15 years
ago there was no over it was that was
somebody's wedding were you nervous
about sharks back then I wasn't now I am
because there's so many [ __ ] seals in
San Francisco Bay I wouldn't I wouldn't
swim there anymore although then - we
did we did there was another swim they
did called the Alcatraz shark fest where
you swim from Alcatraz - to the shore
and that that made you think when you're
out in the water like I'm doing the
shark fest what the [ __ ] I might
yep you feel be delusional II feel safe
because of the numbers of people right
well that's the that's the thing is
there's always these currents and
there's lots of waves so you're in like
these troughs of waves and there's
nobody you can you know can't see
anybody there's nobody near you and then
you come up this yeah exactly top well
this one I actually you know usually
it's like a story like this it's usually
top not Tom's fault you know yeah
but this week it was totally Tom's fault
swimming under the Golden Gate what are
you a John Steinbeck novel even in the
80s or 90s that wasn't a thing to do Tom
I yeah I'm saying it was it was so you
know those those people in Rio they're
gonna get the shit's from their swim by
the way by the way Tom Tom it's a
completely different thing with the
rotten runoff in Rio all the favelas
don't have plumbing so all the water
drains right into a couple different
places in the ocean and I've been in
that water you gotta get a Hep C shot
before you get in it right it is the
shit's you get from that water I went
wakeboarding in Rio in the [ __ ] babe
it's all set is the shit's you get or
you're like pink sock [ __ ] throwing
up Burt you were a [ __ ] incredible
guest you'd like to promote I'm doing
oddball tours go see the eyeball then
and then our special comes out to show
times October or November and just go
check out my podcast and whatever and
I'll be at Stan that's Dale this weekend
so check that out Tom and John do you
anything recording from Schober studios
right now they're helping us out so I
just want to give a quick shout out and
then maybe we can check out their web
mm you Cobras studios.com their Facebook
and Twitter's at Sjogren's studios you
can check them out and check out some
other pockets they have like Venus
Ullman Show and sorry I've been so busy
so thank you to that gentleman who runs
the place
for helping us out man and Tom and me
might use my Twitter not show any time
and you can buy my album manual I'm at
Tom Dogg on Twitter and doing a show at
the proctors in Schenectady with the
great nori Davis oh great
where I go great yeah he's funny like
we're acting like Mel Brooks is back
also check on all things comedy and the
all things comedy page there's a ton of
great product casts there really are yes
absolutely guys thank you so much cast
is next
I wouldn't want listen I've guessed we
say that like it's gonna be the next
channel and stay tuned guys just gonna
magically come on here alright thank you
guys have a good one thanks Bert
thanks for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast here's where you can see
our hosts performing live this week Dan
st. Germain is going to be at stand-up
Scottsdale yes that Scottsdale Arizona
right there
near Phoenix if you live there please go
see him this weekend he'll be there
Thursday Friday Saturday go see him tell
your friends that live in the Phoenix
area to go see him he'll have a great
time Sean Donnelly is going to be at the
Fishtown Premium show at the Philly
punchline this Sunday for more
information on their shows go to Dan st.
Germain net and check out his schedule
and Sean Donnelly comedy comm and check
out his shows thomas attila lewis that's
me you can see me at Proctor's theatre
this Saturday with the great nori Davis
that's gonna be a really fun show come
on out please please please click on
iTunes the next time you get a chance
click on the stars right up just one
sentence about our show we'd appreciate
it
recent thanks go to character 92 J
Stanley o 8 1 9 mag key 321 Ashante bob
friend without a face dante dance
grooves and maddie rose who came to see
us at Just for Laughs Maddy rose thanks
for coming out
also Sam j-dog and iron word these are
just some folks who have clicked on
their iTunes and written a quick review
and click on some stars it really really
helps out our show you have no idea so
if you haven't done it yet
that'd be great also if you haven't done
it yet drop us a note at my dumb friends
podcast at gmail.com we'd love to hear
from you
and if you noticed in our show we
regularly are doing our mailbag segment
and we will do another one very soon
we'll be back next week thank you for
other cool comedy podcasts go to all
things comedy calm yes we're a part of
the all things comedy Network we're one
of many great comedy podcasts that's all
things comedy
our opening and closing song is called
Mary the boxer by Phil Pickens you can
find out more about Phil at Phil Pickens
com
no it's not possible
you